so
so
foreign
foreign
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy week five everybody hopefully
you're awake and ready to go unlike the
new york jets right now congrats to
everyone that rode with us last week and
one big on the mike evans
record-breaking pass pretty good week to
be along for the squad ride that being
said let's keep it rolling right here
we're good to go you just tapped into
the vr betting squad ride live in the
bleacher report app presented by
draftkings i'm connor rogers alongside
the man of the people always good to
have him here greg ivory greg give me
the over under on the hoodies giving
away today let's get that hoodies
just take the over take set the line
high and then take the over and in fact
connor i'm about to give out a hoodie
right now i'm about to give out a hoodie
right now i got mikey draco mikey draco
is in the comments saying winners only
please he got he caught my attention
shout out to you mikey draco you are
walking away with the hoodie connor
let's get this thing going man let's get
this thing going that's right as you say
winners only please that's what we're
looking for on this show we want
touchdown locks anytime touchdown
scoring locks who's getting in the
promised land and as always on friday we
asked you on social we asked you in the
app to drop your locks of who's gonna
score a touchdown here's the most
popular picks you sent us alvin kamara
at the top always a popular choice
davonte adams the target monster justin
jefferson building off that great rookie
season stefan diggs old reliable i think
you'll see him at some point on this
show antonio gibson darren waller corey
davis playing right now needs to really
step it up in the second half and no
offense who's had an up and down season
for the broncos all right and to get
things going here let's take a look at
some of our favorite lock legend videos
from last week that weren't featured on
the show
all right boys school of the squad rhyme
this week today's news is who do i think
we're going to catch that record setting
from tom brady this week there's
something on my car let's give it a
chance here we go
tyler johnson that's your luck brady the
grant plus 300 it's long
all right greg know you got the hoodies
no you got the jerseys to give away do
what you do best
that's right connor i'm giving out
hoodies and i'm giving away not one but
two nfl jersey gift cards connor
one goes to the winning lock legend and
one goes to a lucky commenter so stay
here stay tapped in and keep commenting
because you could be a winner too uh
get in those comments
do what you do you want a jersey
you want a hoodie
you know what i need i need gifts i need
emojis and i need winners only please
somebody just got a hoodie for saying
that so
come on guys
think let's go
our cake's in there
get it done we have four legendary
locked lock legends to show you today as
always it's the squad ride the last one
standing is the squad ride leader they
get the title they get the jersey enough
is enough it's time for round one let's
get this done our first pitch comes from
levi heinecke 57. tell us who's scoring
the touchdown today levi
what's up vr betting we have an anytime
touchdown prop bet my man gordo's going
to decide between stefan diggs and
darren muller
come on
buddy staphon digs
there we have it staffing for locking it
in at plus 120.
i am not a cat guy but i am a staphon
diggs guy so i like the choice a lot man
this is going to be interesting we got
our first decision of the day we need
our second contender the second pitch
from pete's a king 95 what are you
showing us today pete
so i'm doing the crossboard puzzle this
morning and look what falls in my lap
37 down touchdown score lock of the week
let's see here
noah
faint
book it it's a lock folks
you heard the man book it it's a lock no
fan plus 240 we're getting a little
juicy here this guy must have mistaken
this for the boldest bet section i like
it though you've heard our first two
pitches
greg you riding with the catnip legend
or the crossword legend
connor before i jump in here let me talk
to the people
everybody watching please let us know
let us know if we should ride with
stefan diggs the catnip legend or if we
should ride with no offense in the
crossword legend uh connor not a big cat
guy myself not a big cat guy myself but
i must admit i felt the vibes
from the beginning of the video i just
felt good vibes good energy and uh
the pick also resembles that good vibes
and good energy stefan diggs taking on
chiefs
i i like that plus money i like that
plus money so i'll lean this way connor
which way
are you leaning i'm with you with the
crossword legend
no i'm with you all the way catnip
legend i just like the pick i like
stefon diggs pick i think fans a little
risky
i think that's going to be a shootout
the bills and the chiefs man that's i
can't believe that game's not a pickum
with how close i think it's going to be
so i'm excited to watch diggs in that
matchup
i want to know what are the comments
saying right now we gotta get through
this round one what do the people want
i got pat kenny pat kenny says digs and
it ain't a thing digs and it ain't even
a thing shout out to you pat kenny you
are walking away with a hoodie i got mad
dodger matt dodgers in the comments
saying dig shout out to you mad dodger
you were walking away with the hoodie i
got one more for us connor one more i
got dse
joe biano dse joe biano that is for the
producers it says me either greg dog
vibes only
i mean yeah i like what they did there
that's actually pretty funny uh shout
out to you uh
dsc you were walking away with hoodie
but connor connor connor seriously i'm
looking at the comments and it looks
like a runaway it it appears that it's a
runaway i see diggs digs digs digs digs
one more hoodie keith uh oh he went
riley keith rightly keep your walk away
with hoodie uh diggs is an easy pick so
therefore connor it appears
catnip legend stefan diggs
is moving on to the next round all right
levi heineke 57 the catnip legend stefan
diggs the people are riding with you
greg and i are riding with you but
that's only for round one we still have
two challengers remaining on to round
two let's get it done our next pitch
comes from d jones
1983. all right d jones bring it what do
you got for us
what's up guys it's derek here from
south mississippi i saw the guys over at
vr betting trying to do some video pics
for a show the squad ride i had to do
one i'll make this short since i'm on a
family camping trip it's halloween
season so there's only one way to make
this kick
if you want to bed at any time score
sunday look no further than every week
score and aaron rodgers favorite reds on
target he's number 17 on the field but
the number one td lot none other than
devonta adams lock it in with confidence
and let's cash those tickets baby the
pumpkin legends on the family vacation
you gotta respect it and i love the pick
devonte adams the target monster i love
the pumpkin i love the pick greg this is
gonna be tough are you riding with the
catnip legend or is the pumpkin legend
the new challenger taking over in round
two
this one is tough this one is tough it's
so tough connor let me ask the people
let me ask the because i i just need
that energy from you guys you guys let
me know should we rock with devonta
adams here
should we rock with like really think
about that should we rock with devonta
adams here or should we go with stefan
diggs
against that kansas city chiefs defense
uh connor
the video let me talk about the video it
really put me in the halloween mood i
was really feeling you know
yeah spooky saw all the the pumpkins and
you know didn't know was going to pop up
and then we see a number 17
white pumpkin and
i know
i went to the niner game when they faced
the packers not too long ago was two
weeks ago
and
aaron rodgers was looking for 17 quite
often throughout that game
all day i think anything's gonna change
i mean
he's been doing that for i mean how many
seasons now looking for 17 like i just
think it's going to continue to happen
so i might be leaning towards this
devonta adams i might be leaning towards
this devonta adams pit connor i don't
know which way are you leaning i'm with
devonte as well d jones brought the
creativity he brought the holiday vibes
he took some time out on his family
vacation to get it done and most
importantly i just love the pick but hey
who cares what i think what do the
comments think they got to decide a
brutal round too right now
brutal round two indeed connor i am in
the comments and the comments are
jumping man my comments are jumping we
got anthony lindenman posting the same
comment so that does not reward you a
hoodie anthony lindemann but i will read
your comment he says
adams is a lock he says adams is a lock
i mean i do agree shout out to devonta
adams uh here we go
chris paul the goat says digs all day
digs all day shout out to you hey hey
connor
it's back and forth in the comments it's
back and forth in the comments so the
next one i choose i'm just gonna rock
with that one all right
let's get it done i'm just gonna rock
that one we're just gonna rock with that
one here we go i got
jeff butler 77 jetbutler 77 says devante
adams baby
so there it is i'm calling it pumpkin
legend
dj jones 1983
devonta adams is moving on to the next
round love the pick uh shout out to d
jones well done on the family vacation
you're not the squad ride leader yet we
got one more round it's time for the
winner take oh winner take the title
winner take the jersey you know what it
is right now all right next up is cozy
coza
final round let's see the pick cozy
alrighty guys we need some locks this
weekend to get put on deck
what options do we have
no way
honestly still not sure what sport that
is
tempting
there we go
and what do we have to put on few
i'm digging it let's go
the record legend
my man's got quite the collection right
there i love the creativity we talked
about alvin kamara at the top of the
show the favorite pick he was the leader
up there it's kind of a blood bath this
is kind of a one and two camara devonta
adams
pumpkin legend record legend greg you
lean in one way or the other here this
is tough
connor let me talk to the people you
guys let me know which way we should
you guys let me know which way we should
rock because this is the squad ride this
isn't greg's ride this isn't connor's
ride this is the squad ride so you guys
get in the comments and tell me which
way we should lean
i
personally want to lean towards devonta
adams uh we talked about it conor even
my guy the pumpkin legend himself uh dj
d jones said it in his video that
devante adams is aaron rodgers
favorite target in the red zone so i
mean favorite target anywhere they go
that's that's also a fact any anywhere
on the field for a 17 is uh aaron
rodgers favorite target but
i'm leaning towards devonta items love
the video for album kamir love the
creativity that is also a good pick too
but
look at the odds i'm gonna just go with
the minus 140 devonte adam 17 give it to
me which way are you leaning connor i'm
leaning the same way right here i'm
going to stay loyal to the pumpkin right
i'm going to stay loyal to the devonta
adams
camaro's been kinda up and down as that
touchdown guy right now i i know the
saints have been a weird team this year
green bay you never know what you're
gonna get but you always feel good about
one thing with them that's the
connection of rogers and adams and the
way they get it done
you're rolling with adams i'm rolling
with adams is the comment section with
us is the pumpkin squad ride contender
getting across the finish line right now
hey they're back and forth in the
comments i got i love ranch rocking with
alvin kamara he has kamara uh he has a
gift here
shout out to you i love rant joe yan joe
yan is in the comments talking about
devonta adams he says this guy with a
devonta adam's gift there it is i'm
gonna show you guys there it is joey
shout out to your walk away with hoodie
larry hall of fame larry hall of fame
says adams he's rocking with adam shout
out to you larry you were walking away
with the hoodie uh i got one more one
more
jesse24 jesse24
says adams hey it's a runaway connor i'm
gonna just start giving away
here we go i heart steve zero seven zero
four says adams
they're gonna they're gonna cut me off
so i would just stop before they do uh
everybody that i mentioned you guys are
walking away with hoodie and you know
what that means connor
that means the pumpkin legend
devonte adams my guy d jones 1983
is the winner of this week's squad rise
shout out to you uh we're gonna sing you
something uh dj jones and
you guys
get in get on draftkings and bet the
squad ride send us your screenshots of
your bets
let's get rich this sunday send us your
videos and your celebrations we want
winners and winners only please connor
how you feeling about this devonta
adam's pick i'm feeling good i love it
listen we this is gonna be a sneaky good
game i think a lot of people don't
realize the bengals are three and one
just like the packers the bengals are
gonna be feeding off that home crowd
which is good for this pick it's gonna
be a back and forth game it's not gonna
be a blowout the packers shouldn't be
sitting on the ball they're gonna be
throwing the ball so devonte adams the
target monster that he always is
let's cash in some checks here let's
make some money this week on the devonta
adams i'm absolutely loving it we're not
done we got a squad ride leader but i
know you still got more to give away we
got community bets we got boldest bets
we got locks to give away we got that
jersey let's have some fun let's get
into the community comment contest as we
always do if you hang out in the br
betting community streaming the vr app
you know about this already we ask you
every week what did you learn from the
previous weeks what are you picking up
from this nfl season we picked our two
favorite comments and we want to know
what you think greg let's get right into
it
i need you guys to get in the comments
and tell me which of these is the better
take i'm giving a hoodie to whoever you
choose let's take a look at the first
comment from my guy
dt i'ma just call him dt connor he says
the dogs have no training this year
killing parlays left and right somebody
called the dog whisper please hold on
hold on hold on
there's nothing wrong with the little
dog barking connor there's nothing wrong
with the little dog barking that's
that's the plus money isn't that what we
like absolutely absolutely i'm all about
this right now i like when the safe
money gets nuked man it's fun it's what
makes this fun
listen no risk it no biscuit all right
let's keep it moving
no risk it no biscuit let's keep it
moving hey pierre this is not the tag
for the beat but this is actually
somebody who commented his name is a
pierre uh let's take a look at his
comment
uh here it is here it is it's like this
every year when in doubt take the point
in the nfl any given sunday wow i i i
guess this is just a dog barking sunday
this week on connor man everybody's
talking about the dogs and good for them
great job by apr bringing some rational
thinking to the squad ride right listen
there is nothing wrong with taking the
points or taking the upset make that
money back have some fun we've seen it
week after week so far this year there's
been tons of upsets whether it's college
whether it's nfl we're having fun with
it i'm with a pierre that is great
betting advice for this week
yes sir connor i'm in the comments man i
don't have the handy dandy ipad today
but i got his cousin i got his cousin
andy
the handy-dandy phone and i'm in the
comments seeing what they're talking
about i got jj snell says nah dawg so i
feel like he's vibing with us and we
like the dogs we like the vlog shout out
to you jj esnell you were walking away
with the hoodie also dt vt you are
walking away with a hoodie for your take
uh
let me give out some more hoodies let me
get some some more hoodie sports feed
says apierre
apierre word up shout out to you sports
feed you're walking away with a hoodie
uh
i got one more in me connor uh i heart
steve0704 says apierre knows what's up
that's a that's a tag for like a beat
you know
to tag so that's why people are vibing
in the comments
all right the api boldest bets shout out
to apierre well done but it's time for
our boldest bets of the week we got the
comment contest now it's the boldest
bets listen it's bad luck to talk about
a hot streak so i'm not gonna do that
right now but i am heating up a little
bit on the boldest bets the two
touchdown scorers have been good to me
let's keep this going let's keep this
good luck going on the boldest bets greg
what do we need from the people during
this time of the show
get in the comments and tell me if
you're riding with me or if you're
riding with connor probably ride with
connor he's been hot
time to cool off though i'm nervous man
i'm nervous
uh connor who you got talk to us all
right we're gonna get away from the two
touchdown scorers this week we hit on
mike williams two weeks ago tyree kill
last week we're just gonna kinda
unfortunately be harsh with the houston
texans here i don't think they could
score any points i know new england's
offensive line is out for this game
mostly but i don't think it really
matters i don't think houston could have
put up any points on new england so
we're going patriots to win by 19 to 24
points essentially a blowout greg what
do you got for us this week
connor i had to tap in with my guy matt
dodger saw him in the comments had to
ask him hey man
what's a bold bet that the people should
ride this week
he told me
don't go far because he's from l.a he
said let's go to la let's go to la
chargers browns
take the alternate spread browns minus
four chargers are coming off an
emotional game browns are coming off of
a hard fought road game
like the browns in this matchup they're
the dogs here connor we were just
talking about the dogs they are the dogs
alternate spread them to minus four plus
210 take it shout out to my guy mad
dodger we're rocking we're rolling
man i i like it listen this is a good
browns team we think they're one of the
better rosters in the nfl
chargers young fun team we know they'll
be feeding off the home vibes a little
bit but that is not a lot of points my
man what are the people saying are they
leaning one way or the other
connor's hot but greg is consistent
uh anthony dashi dash a shout out to you
anthony uh that was literally the first
thing i saw connor i didn't even yeah i
don't even know why i read that one
shout out to you uh here we go uh jason
wade13 says browns shout out to you uh
connor is in fuego neil noose neil deuce
shout out to you uh
trashed says lfg those are good vibes
d-boy 22 says connor has the lock d-boy
22 says connor has to lock one more
connor oh i got one more
give me the browns connors pick
us a little too risky i'm sorry the the
the english there was wasn't the bad
vibes anyway connor let's just keep it
going
just keep it going man
i love it you give away that jersey yet
by the way i don't want you keeping that
journey let me give you your pocket too
long let me give it away let me get it
away right now logan
l3i ggz
gotta roll with greg thank you brother
you're walking away with a jersey and i
got mystical wheat mystical mystical
winner says i'm going with connor on
this one
shout out to you mystical you're walking
away with a hoodie the other person got
a jersey
we're well balanced this week man i
gotta got to do we got the risk takers
we got the people going with the browns
we got all kinds of good things going
right now which of course means good
luck with your wagers we want people on
this show to win we want devonte adams
to score we want the lock legends to
keep those videos coming congrats to all
our hoodie winners jersey winners if you
won vr betting is going to dm you in the
next 24 hours have no fear vr betting is
going to get back to you thanks to
everyone that commented the comment
section has been awesome every single
week we've done this show thanks to our
legends levi heinecke 57 the catnip
legend pizza king 95 the crossword
genius d jones 1983 bringing it from
vacation with the pumpkin and he's our
squad ride leader and of course cozy
coza with the record collection you
gotta love that enjoy your football
sunday drop your real time takes in the
sports betting community stream in the
vr app and follow us especially if you
want to keep up with greg follow those
ig stories all day always entertaining
alongside greg ivory i'm connor rogers
see you same time same place next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you